yesterday we started the show with a
full analysis of the new Trump
Republican tax plan how will the plan
affect businesses middle class people
rich people whoever today we're going to
start with the question how does the new
tax plan affect Donald Trump personally
he has said many times this tax plan
isn't good for him believe me folks he
said it so many times but I'm going to
play just one example of when he most
recently said this I think or at least
somewhat recently we're doing everything
we can to reduce the tax burden right on
you and your family by eliminating tax
breaks and loopholes we will ensure that
the benefits are focused on the middle
class the working men and women not the
highest income earners
our framework includes our explicit
commitment that tax reform will protect
low-income and middle-income households
not the wealthy go on and well-connected
they can call me all they want it's not
gonna help I'm doing the right thing and
it's not good for me you believe me
believe them well actually it turns out
he can't be believed the reality is the
exact opposite of what Donald Trump said
here and what he said so many times this
is a very good tax plan for Donald Trump
there's a new estimate from the Center
for American Progress and it says that
Trump will probably save fifteen million
dollars per year as a result of this tax
plan the estate tax changes could save
his heirs as much as four and a half
million additional dollars Jared Kushner
will save about twelve million dollars
per year five other Trump inner circle
members are each going to save millions
of dollars in fact Wilbur Ross Stephen
minuchin Linda McMahon Betsy DeVos and
Rex Tillerson they'll each save about
four and a half million dollars a year
savings per year as a result of this tax
bill think of the math for a second okay
seven people seven people in total they
will save about 49 and a half million
dollars in one year on taxes if the
average family will save $1,200 a year
on taxes which at one point was the
number the Republicans put out that
means that these seven people will say
49 and a half million dollars a year on
taxes and then 41,000 other families
will share another forty nine and a half
million dollars in savings or put it
another way imagine 99 million dollars
in total savings from this tax plan
there are seven people who will get half
of those savings and 41,000 other
families that will share the other half
of that savings great plan right very
profitable presidency for Donald Trump
increasingly yeah but this is all legal
though I mean when we probably doubt the
fact that he could be violating the
emoluments
when he lets foreign dignitaries state
his hotels yeah we talk about alleged
collusion with the Russians you know
maybe there's some financial crime some
money laundering and involved there but
this is the stuff that you can do as
president and completely fine totally
lutely and totally legal the opposite of
what he promised but absolutely and
totally legal and sort of uh this is
kind of funny the Wharton School at the
University of Pennsylvania
Trump's alma mater as he's told us ad
nauseam they did an analysis which says
that this plan is going to increase the
debt somewhere in the range of one point
nine to two point two trillion dollars
they have a higher estimate than what
the Congressional Budget Office came
away with they say that the vast
majority of the debt increase is from
the reductions in taxes to the top one
percent of our country the failing fake
news Wharton School of Business that I
went to and brag about all the time is
putting out the fake news about my tax
plan he fire them in some sort of way
yeah is this the type of winning that he
was talking about how does this make
America great again to give a forty nine
and a half million dollar tax break to
Trump his son-in-law and five of his
important inner circle members if this
is what you voted for then you're very
very happy most of you didn't vote for
this and I'm curious what you're
thinking at this point today's episode
is sponsored in part by a harmony if
you've tried online dating you've
probably run into lazy text messages
dead end conversations random matches
that don't turn into dates you can't get
to know someone by looking at a picture
producer Pat knows that after all a
harmony is not like many other dating
sites in that they take steps that other
dating sites don't in order to find you
a more compatible match they're built to
help you find lasting meaningful
relationships it's not a shallow hook-up
site and they've helped over a million
people find their perfect match using
years and years of science data and
psychological research to send you the
right matches a harmony brings
compatible people together right now our
listeners and viewers can get a free
month with
harmony when you sign up for a
three-month subscription if you enter
the code Pakman at checkout stop waiting
start your journey to a satisfying
meaningful relationship can be fun to
play around with online dating apps but
when you're actually ready to find
someone and have a meaningful
relationship with them there's one app
that's built to bring you real love and
that's a harmony come see how a harmony
can change your life go to e harmony
comm and get started enter my code pack
minute check out that's PA que ma n